Faces are possibly the most important visual stimuli
that we perceive.
The moment you see a person’s face, you
can infer their race, age, mood, identity,
and possibly their gender expression (always ask).
Unless, of course, you have prosopagnosia,
aka ‘face blindness’ --
where you can’t tell familiar or unfamiliar faces apart.
Prosopagnosia is important because severe
sufferers of the disorder have reported difficulty
recognizing not only faces, but also animals
and objects, like cars.
Do you have a friend who can see a car and be like,
“that’s a 1995 Subaru Outback, 2 Door,
with a leather interior?”
Or a friend who can look at a dog and be like,
“Hmm, 50% American Staffordshire
and 50% Coton de Tulear...”?
Well, these people have too much time on their
hands, but more importantly they have expertise
for these objects and animals that they probably
learned over time.
The same nodes in our brains linked to facial
recognition also help us distinguish animals,
objects, and even car types.
These areas, discovered using fMRI, include
the occipital face area, the fusiform face area,
superior temporal sulcus, and an old
friend, the amygdala.
Those parts of the brain light up because
the way people build expertise for dog breeds
and cars is the same way we do it for faces.
If you’re consistently around diverse faces,
you can more easily tell them apart.
If not, we call this sociological and psychological
phenomenon “own-race bias.”
The theory of own-race bias posits that
people tend to be better at recognizing faces from their own race than across races.
(We're talking about race here as a combination of socially significant physical features...
because we all know by now there's no biological
basis to race...
right?)
Own-race faces are better remembered when
compared with memory for faces of another,
less familiar race, and this is called the
“cross race effect.”
And it starts mad early.
In 2013, a group of researchers found out
that babies as young as two months old
prefer faces compared to other geometric shapes.
This shows that even as a baby, we’re building
facial expertise.
But if you’re building your facial expertise up
from a young age
in a racially homogenous community,
those are all the faces you know, so, of course,
you’d know your racial in-group extremely well.
As for anyone outside of your race, you’re
gonna have a tough time, my guy.
“See, Mamoudou told me I’m not racist!”
First of all, I did not say that.
CRE does exist, but it’s not a blanket excuse
for not telling people apart.
This goes all the way from telling Octavia
Spencer and Viola Davis apart
to being able to discern between two Asian coworkers.
Even I’ve been confused for my friend Yedoye
and we don’t look the same...
we’re just black at the same time!
Not only that, but the cross-race effect makes
eyewitness testimony less reliable,
because what if the dude on the stand can’t tell Black or Asian people apart
and someone gets wrongfully convicted?
Some evidence shows that simply being aware
of the CRE can help your brain focus
on more subtle differences of faces, and thus treat
people in other race groups as individuals
and not just people who are part of a
monolithic “other” group.
The cross-race effect is something to keep in mind when you can’t tell people from another race apart,
but it shouldn’t be
an excuse for not trying.
After all, if you can tell Pokémon, cars,
and dogs apart,
you definitely can tell me and Yedoye apart.
I mean, we're both devilishly handsome...
but we just aren't the same person.
Hey what's up? Thanks for hangin'.
Speaking of facial recognition, do you think
your DNA could be giving away
what your face looks like?
Check out this video right here to find out
if your DNA is out here snitchin' on your face.
Be sure to subscribe to Seeker for more hot
science content every single day.